before you recorded the previous yep we
can
um record now um and then you can
share this with representative morgan or
anyone else who wasn't able to be here
we'll we'll save this to the cloud
um and then that will give us a link
that we can share after if that's okay
representative edwards that's your call
we can stop
i think we should go ahead and record it
because
uh for uh representative nordgren in
case she's interested
okay and then i don't know if it needs
to be uh
available to the public or not since
it's an orientation but
okay yes fyi representative edwards uh
karen rounds is
yes oh there you are
i see you all right i apologize
as chair division three of the house
finance committee i find that due
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covet 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public meeting pertaining to
division orientation matters
please note that there is no physical
location for members
of the public to observe and listen
uh contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
through this meeting through the zoom
electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91 a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting
should email lba
underscore fiscal f i s c a
l at l e g dot state
dot nh dot u s in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
there will be no voting today though
let's start the meeting by taking
roll call attendance when each member
states their
pres when each member identifies
themselves
please state your presence also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting
and that's required by the right to know
law so
um mr vice chair are you ready to take a
role
i'm i know the role i don't actually
have the list
i mean i know who the people are but
whatever
what you're you're you're the guy
whatever you want to do there i thought
you wanted the clerk to call them i
think that's the guy that should be
doing it
i'm sorry that's a clerk role you're
right all right
clerk are you ready i am representative
edwards
i'm here i'm in my office in auburn
uh nobody's in the office with me my
family's in the house though
representative erv i am alone i'm here
and i'm alone in my home office
representative weiler i'm in kingston on
the road alone in this room but there
are others in the house
i'm here i'm in guildford at my home my
wife's
roaming around here somewhere okay
representative representative wallner is
here i'm in concord
we've decided this is excused or
likely to come late well i just got a
text from her and she's on her way but
she will be a little bit late
okay representative rogers i'm here um
chairman we're all here except for
the lord will come late thank you
so um i did send an agenda for today
the next item up after the attendance or
member introductions
just to get to know each other it's a
little awkward because you guys know
each other
and i don't i don't really know you all
very well some of you have written to me
which was very helpful but so i'm jess
edwards i'm a retired
uh army officer i had a hybrid career
stretching for one-third of a century to
the day 33 years and four months
i was a medical service corps officer
which
is a basically hospital administrator
operating units out in the field i was a
comptroller
i was a healthcare informaticist and i
did
large-scale medical operations planning
as well
i got out of active duty though
other than some deployments to
afghanistan
in 91 and i started a parallel career
working for medical device manufacturers
where i was a project management officer
and product manager so i've been around
the healthcare field
you know my dad was in it uh and so my
whole family has kind of been healthcare
oriented
i had a finance degree in
college a couple of master's degrees one
in computer science
and one in systems management and that's
what really prepared me for
kind of the healthcare informaticist
role so
i'm really excited by this opportunity
looks like
representative nordgren has joined us
and um
i'm a big nebraska football college
football fan i grew up
starting to attend going to school going
to games with my dad
and i'm married this is uh the
year of our 40th anniversaries got two
kids
two daughters uh elizabeth some of you
may know
she was a state rep for two terms uh
she's the one that got me interested so
i could family joke is i
i needed to run to counteract all our
votes so that's just a family joke
but in any case i i really enjoy
the state house it's my third term i was
in
health and human services the first term
and then ways and means
and so i feel like i've got a good
background for this but i need you all
to
be patient and train me a little bit and
that's it for me um representative earth
you want to go
[Music]
hi i'm keith irv it's good to see you
all again
hi karen a long time
uh i've served in division three last
term
um not much last spring but very much
the year before
uh i'm you all know me so i won't go
into
quite so much detail i basically have my
own software business and i'm married
representative weiler yes uh
graduated from mit in 63 got married
went to pilot training
six years of active duty when i got
through with my
vietnam tour i went into american
airlines and the reserves
and stayed american for 30 years
and had a total of 30 years with the air
force retiring as a colonel
i've been in the legislature since 1990
first came on uh at the time i think it
was an appropriations committee in 94.
at a couple of years i wasn't on finance
committee but i have about 24 years on
finance committee
mostly on division two i think i had one
term on division three
a division one rather first time on
division three i'm going to learn
something
thank you god i'm married with uh
living in kingston for 50 years my
family grew up here and
some of my grandchildren grew up here so
do you can you hear me do you still fly
nope we had had a uh
had a landing in a uh cessna 185
two years ago and the guy that was with
me said when's the last time you landed
i said 17 years ago
a little rusty i was going to recruit
you for the
legislative squadron of the civil air
patrol but
okay hey thank you for also volunteering
to be our clerk
i i i was really kind of nervous about
that
i've had a lot of experience with that
even on this division
division but division two so how about
how about you representative bean what
do you what do you want to share with us
sir
can you hear me i can hear you
well i got i got married when i was 16.
i'll be married 50 years this year
i got two children i spent three years
on the budget committee in
guilford and obviously two years on the
i'm a contractor construction worker and
i own some apartments in the city of
wrestler so
are you still there yeah you want it
sounded like you went into a tin can for
a moment
oh i think there was other noise on the
on the tablet
i don't know i don't know where i left
off professional armor
professional arm wrestler so so if we
have a
cross committee um championship out
we'll nominate you for that
98 i took second in the world right
handed and third left
oh wow all right representative walter
can you beat that
no i i'm not an arm wrestler that's for
sure
i'm mary jane walner and i'm
been in the legislature for i guess
this is my 21st term so i'll be going on
42 years in the legislature
and i've served on the health and human
service committee
the child and family law committee and
most of my time has been i've been on
the finance committee for 24 years
for a couple of terms i was the majority
leader i was also the deputy minority
leader
one term um i've been
i spent most of my time on division
three
and i am retired at this point
i was the director of a child care
agency
i have two children one lives in texas
and one lives in massachusetts
oh okay um well if you see me doing
something wrong
representative nordron i'm sorry i was a
little late
um i've been in the legislature since
88 and i was on the board of selectmen
in hanover and
chair for the years before i became
a legislator um i was on
i think children use an elderly is what
it was called mary jane
when i was on it with you and then
she went to the appropriations committee
probably ken was there and then i
joined her and can in 92
and i've always been on division three i
think that's what it's called um
and i have five doctors in my family so
i sort of know
a little bit about the health care
system um
and i have a son in california and a
daughter
that's it hey representative rogers
what what would you like to share well
i'm starting my eighth term in the
legislature
um and i served on public works
committee when i was first here
um served on criminal justice served on
the long range capital planning
and on finance for the last i think the
last four terms
i've been on division one in a division
three um
interesting tidbit about finance when i
was
in gosh i think it was second and third
grade i used to attend appropriation
meetings with my mother my mother was
the um
administrative assistants to what was
then called the warden of the state
prison
but he actually ran the corrections
department and he used to come and
present the budget
um actually my mother presented the
budget she answered all the questions
and i remember at night when we'd go
home she spoke about the
appropriations committee a little
differently than she did when she
appeared before them during the day
so i had that perspective when i was
growing up about
how some of the members of the
appropriations committee
dealt with the employees so that i guess
gave me a good training of
how to deal with people that came and
appeared before the committee
because i remembered how some of them
dealt with my mom
and that was good training i think
um i have lived in concord my entire
life
and went to schools here i have served
as
a prosecutor most of my adult life was
the first
female prosecutor of county attorney for
merrimack county
and have served as a police prosecutor
so my background is in criminal justice
i have probably my greatest interest in
division
is the children and youth part of it
especially
um a great deal of interest in ydc
and with what happens with sununu and
the amount of money we're spending there
and what we're getting out of it
and um i think we'll all find a lot of
interest there i know representative
weiler knows the
complete sinkhole i guess is one word of
using of what we've dealt with there
um i also share with you representative
edwards a
great love of dogs and while i'm not a
college football fan i grew up with my
dad taking me
to the new england patriots or what was
in the boston patriots games
from when i was a child we would go to
the games
every year and i recently found um our
first tickets to the games he was a
season ticket holder
first year and the tickets were five
dollars a seat
now i still have inherited his season
tickets
and let's just say they're a little more
than five dollars a seat
um unfortunately but um i'm a huge
football fan
so we can share that as well when we
tend to disagree on a lot of other
things at least we have dogs in football
well i've been learning how to become a
patriots fan i found like
that it was uh essential to my new
career
so so uh so mr
kane do you want to tell us a little bit
about yourself
or do you think everyone knows you
no i um i can tell that i'll start my
video
so hi my name is mike kane and i'm the
legislative budget assistant for the
state of new hampshire
uh just a brief background i grew up in
quincy massachusetts and
went to college at merrimack college
moved into up to new hampshire
in the 90s in my previous
career i worked with the house ways and
means committee down in massachusetts
as a budget analyst working on some
transportation issues including big dig
financing
as well as funding of the mbta which is
their train
system down in massachusetts and then
moved up here with my wife jennifer
and i have three kids i've been in the
lba for 21 years
recently appointed the lba in 2015. so
so so mr ripple sir
or yes uh kevin ripple i think i know
pretty much everybody here
except i haven't met representative bean
yet um
but i look forward to working with you
all i've been with the lba
prior to that i got a master's degree in
public administration
and in 2007 upon graduating i went to
work for the audit division
i stayed there for about five and a half
years before
volunteering with the budget division
for the 2013 budget session
and then i started full time with the
budget division
that summer i started out with division
one was there for a couple years and
i've been here with division three
thank you so did uh
karen rounds this is uh this is a little
uh unexpected but
you probably know yourself well enough
to tap dance through an intro
sure sure i'd be happy to um to share a
little bit uh first of all it's great to
see you all
and welcome to the community
representative edwards um
it it's uh it doesn't feel like it's
been two years since we were all
together but i guess it really has been
um i'm karen rounds i am the chief
financial officer for the department of
health and human services as kevin will
tell you more about i'm sure
later we have about a 2.6 billion dollar
budget a year
a large majority of which are federal
funds
many of which cannot be earned without
the matching
general funds um i
am a cpa uh i have an accounting degree
i have worked for hhs for three years
or almost three years before that i
worked for the department of revenue
as their assistant revenue assistant
audit director
and as an auditor prior to that which is
why um as many of you know i sometimes
have strong feelings about revenues
and tax policy which i'm now allowed to
have a personal opinion on now that i no
longer work for the department
um but i have great friends over there
and they do a wonderful job
um i uh
what else did i want to share i
currently live in bristol i just put my
house on the market though and i have 30
showings between today and tomorrow
which is insane
if anyone's looking to sell their house
apparently it's a great time
um just moving a little closer to
concord so we'll still be
in the area i do not have any kids i'm
married
14 years similar to representative
rogers
my mom was a town administrator for a
small town in new hampshire
and my brother is a fish and game
officer so we're both very dedicated
to government service and i don't have
children but i have two
amazing nephews seven and three the
seven-year-old who is already well on
his way to being
way smarter than i am so uh
so pretty proud of those too
thank you so mr ripple do you think
uh miss clayman is on the phone
with the lba staff i just see a picture
is it i don't
know humans there uh
let's see he
is and i have uh janet if you're
listening
i just allowed you to talk i think i saw
you show up so if you unroot your phone
janet or computer
you'll be able to introduce yourself
hello we can hear you okay good
you want to say anything about yourself
your background anything
do i oh okay well i'm janet clayman i'm
the legislative assistant for house
finance committee i've been doing
this job since i believe it was 2005.
um i had previously worked for this for
the house
back in 1986 to 1990
and then i left to have a bunch of kids
and um and then i came back like i said
i have four children they're all grown
up
one lives in germany and one lives in
boston and the other two live in sunapee
and i don't know what else you need to
what you want to know about me
i've worked with representative irf and
representative walner and representative
rogers
pretty much and representative wyler
and i can't see if there's anybody else
you folks it's the whole division three
that's for sure and then we've got mr
kane and ripple and
so and karen rounds obviously oh yeah i
saw
karen yeah yep um
so i'm here i'm here to help thank you
i'm looking forward to meeting you in
the real world as soon as this
pandemic goes away that would be very
nice
all right well uh let's go on
uh mr ripple you've got an lba briefing
you want to share with us sir
sure yes and i did email that out to all
the members
but i'll also share my screen here so
it's a little easier for you to see
so you should be able to see my screen
now does that look can everybody see
that
yes okay uh so we'll start from the
beginning there'll be a little bit of
overlap
with mike kane's presentation to the
full committee the other day but that's
okay
um if you take a look at this briefing
on the second page here you can see all
of our contact information
my email address and my office phone
number if anybody needs to get in touch
with me
even though we're not physically present
in the office
i am checking my voicemails so you can
always do that i think i've also
provided representative edwards with my
cell phone number i'm not sure if he
shared that with the committee but
feel free to call me whenever you need
to
as we scroll down we just have a quick
look at the operating budget process
here uh
obviously we're in the governor's phase
the agency put out
its budget request back in october
and from november until the next couple
of weeks the governor is going to be
completing his
proposed budget and by law the governor
has to submit that to the legislature by
february 15th
although i think we've heard that he may
be presenting it a few days earlier this
year possibly on the 11th
and usually shortly after
the governor's proposed budget comes out
a couple weeks later his proposed
trailer bill will come out as well
and the committee will be hearing we'll
be holding a number of meetings on
uh that as well so the house phase
really begins in earnest
in mid-february after the governor has
presented his proposed budget and
the committee will be meeting likely
several times a week
between mid-february and late march
starting in mid-february usually right
away we'll have the agency come in
to talk about the various aspects of
their budget
and we can work out a calendar for that
a little later
at times uh the full finance committee
has heard presentations from each agency
or at least each of the major agencies
prior to the divisions beginning their
work
i'm not sure if that's going to happen
this year or not but
that's a that's a possibility and then
finally after the house
finishes its work in late march we move
on to the senate
that continues on from april through
june and
at the end of june mid to the end of
june there'll be a committee of
conference phase
uh which will at which point we'll wrap
so moving on here we have a list of
helpful websites i won't visit all of
these but they're here for you to peruse
i will just bring you
quickly to our own website
if you go to the lba site and then under
budget division click
on budget and revenue documents that'll
bring you here so we have documents for
all of the operating and capital budgets
going back
to 2010. and if you look at the 2021
page
you can see the type of information that
we tend to put up there we put up all
the major documents
for everybody to see members in the
public alike including
obviously house bills one and two as
they move through the process
the capital budget house bill 25 detail
change reports which are documents that
we produce
showing the changes from
the house finance budget to the
governor's budget
the senate budget to the house budget
etc so you can see what's happened in
each
we'll also post amendment packets here
when the full house finance committee
hears from the divisions they will see
packets
that contain proposed changes to house
bill 1 and house bill 2. we'll post that
here
as well as compare reports surplus
statements etc so all the major
documents get posted here
because this year will be a little bit
different and
we'll be doing more work online and in a
excuse me um
we will also be setting up pages
specific to the divisions
they aren't online yet but we will have
a division three page and the idea
is to post their literally everything
that's distributed throughout the
division's work
so so everything that comes through the
division will ultimately be made
available
online
so scrolling down here the next couple
of pages
are basically different ways of looking
at
the budget we have some tables we have
some pie charts but you can see here
that hhs
which makes up category 5 comprises
almost half of the state general fund
budget
and a little under 43 percent of the
total budget including
scrolling down again more ways of
and once again division three comprises
so i think at that point
i will take you down to the part of the
briefing that's specific to division
three
which begins here on page
and here you can see broken out the
you can see the biggest component by far
we're looking at all funds here and the
office of medicaid services comprises
about 1.1
1.2 billion dollars in total funds out
of a 2.6
so scrolling down we get into some
specific program areas
i'm not necessarily going to go through
all of these in detail i think they're
they're they're here for you to read at
your leisure you don't necessarily have
to hear me
talk at you about them but i am going to
highlight some of the big areas
within the hhs budget and the first one
i'd like
to talk about well i guess we'll gloss
over the child development program and
child protection and family services
first
the child development program among
other things
funds child care scholarships for
families and provides assistance
with the cost of child care so they can
maintain employment
participate in training etc and you can
see here that their operating budget
in fiscal 20 was about 14.3 million
dollars in general funds
and 16 million in general funds in
fiscal 21.
for each of these items i've shown you
the general fund component for the 2021
budget
as well as the general fund component of
the agency's
budget request for 2223 now obviously
that's not going to be the same as the
governor's budget but
for perspective you can see what the
moving down to child protection and
that contains roughly 62 to 68 million
in general funds per year in the current
2021 budget that budget
also added significant funding as did
the one before it
for a variety of positions specifically
child protective service workers
social workers licensed alcohol and drug
counselors who are contracted with the
department
attorneys nurses social worker services
etc
that was in response to an independent
review of dcyf as well as a lot of
items that were in the news a while ago
about the caseload
specifically the the high load per case
worker within dcyf
so i believe that caseload has been
brought down a little bit the department
will be able to speak about and
speak about that in greater detail when
they appear before the committee in a
so moving down we have the sununu youth
services center uh this is always a
hot topic for division three and the
finance division generally
that's because when the sununu center
was constructed back in the early to mid
2000s
it was constructed using partially state
funds partially federal funds
as a 144 bed facility
but over the past several years
specifically over the past four or five
years
a couple of policy changes have resulted
in
uh the daily census of the sununu center
dropping significantly
uh so rather than 144 beds being filled
i think as of the last dashboard that
the department put out
i believe there were 14
juveniles currently occupy currently
occupying the sununu center
and over the last couple of months it's
actually been as low as
nine occupying this new new center so
that's a very large facility for a very
low pop for very small population
there are four wings at the sununu
center i believe currently only two of
them are being used
so it's a large facility it has a large
maintenance budget that's generally
fixed
it has a staffing budget that to some
extent is also fixed for example they
need medical staff 24 hours a day
regardless of how many kids are there
so it'll be um
it'll probably be a hot topic going
forward there have been a number of
commissions
and a number of study committees that
have looked at
the issue of what to do with the sununu
center and how to fund it going forward
took place in 2017 2018
and i can find copies of all those
reports for you if you'd like to take a
look at them
but they recommended converting the
unused pods into either
a privately run substance use disorder
facility for juveniles
or a facility for pregnant teen and teen
and you may know that one of the unused
pods was previously used as a substance
use disorder facility for juveniles but
that i believe is no longer the case
so you can see there that the general
fund component of the sununu center's
budget was 10.6 million
in each year of the 2021 biennium and
that was deliberately designed to remain
flat with the budget in the 1819
biennium
the agency's request going forward is
about 14 million per year and 22 and 23.
and that does include some funding for
so i raised my hand there you probably
oh sorry i didn't see that
um okay so some of these
um physical locations when we get to
rona behind us
i would like to actually uh go see them
have they have they provided tours
before
they have they have and during the last
budget cycle we actually went over all
of division three went over and took a
tour
so yeah i think once covert is behind us
they should be
easily able to do that in the division
of human services is this
where the domestic violence fund is
uh domestic violence i believe is in
human services yes
okay because it's not mentioned here in
in your paragraph so i just wanted to
uh know where it was so it's in here
somewhere
uh people have
raised their hand i may not have hit on
that in this um in this briefing
actually i didn't cover everything but i
can certainly provide information
uh going forward actually domestic
violence might be in um
i think about it that might be in uh
substance use disorder so
okay um and then as you're just
swinging by if you could point out where
new futures
and um wait not wayfair
what what's the name of that way
something
waypoint
where they were they fit in the budget
too okay sure that
that again would be in uh substance use
disorder services when we get there all
right
representative nordgren has her hand up
to
um seems how jessa asked a question i
thought i could ask a question
um so when you're talking about house
bill one and two
you said house bill two was a trailer
bill
i think for the members that are new you
might define what that is
oh okay sure good point uh the trailer
bill
the bill that basically effectuates
all of the changes in the budget that
aren't numbers so in other words if tax
rates change
those would have to be in the trailer
bill because the state supreme court
decided
many years ago back in the 80s i believe
that the budget couldn't
change state law or state statute it
could only appropriate funds
so all the policy areas that pertain to
the budget
are contained in that trailer bill and
it's usually a very big
document it it varies by year but
um it's not uncommon for there to be
several hundred sections
in the trailer bill as it makes its way
through the process
and uh the fact that it's so big is the
reason it usually comes to us a little
bit late the governor usually gets up
that to us a couple weeks after his
proposed budget comes out
and as we go through this process i'm
sure you'll have many proposed
amendments to the trailer bill and
that's something that uh
i think the committee can take a look at
the division of transitional assistance
and tanf temporary assistance to needy
families
this is uh cash assistance and emergency
assistance to families with children in
which
one parent is absent
for one reason or another new hampshire
as as as karen alluded to uh when she
spoke earlier
hhs receives a lot of federal money that
requires
state funds to be spent in order to
receive it and tanf is a good example of
that
new hampshire receives a 38 million
federal block grant
but in order to receive that funding it
has to spend 32 million dollars of state
money as a
so-called maintenance of effort and any
amount that we spend
below our maintenance of effort
requirement results in a corresponding
there is also a tanf reserve account
which isn't a formal account but it's
basically unspent federal tanf funds
and in the past that reserve has been
quite big it's gotten up in the 50
60 million dollar territory however over
the past few years
as eligibility requirements have changed
and his benefit levels have changed
and as the state has relied on tanf
funds
for a wide variety of programs
that reserve amount has has been drawn
down quite a bit
so in the last budget there was a lot of
work
done to try to make sure that the
reserve didn't quote fall below zero
even though it's
impossible for it to actually fall below
zero i think representative wallner has
a question
it's about the tanf reserve fund i
wondered if we knew what the balance of
it is
at this point and i don't know what it
is uh
right now that's not information that we
have access to at the lba we'll have to
go through the department for that
but they should they will be able to
provide that in the next couple weeks
usually
they do provide a long document showing
where all the tanf funds are spent and
the projected balance at the end of the
biennium so we should get that going
forward
great thank you kevin sure
so moving on we have snap the
supplemental nutrition assistance
program this was previously known as
food stamps
uh not a huge state commitment here the
cert
the benefits themselves are 100
federally funded but the administrative
cost is shared 50 50 between the state
i'm going to skip over the state
supplemental programs here old age
assistance a to the permanently and
totally disabled and a to the needy
blind
but we can come back if anybody wants to
talk about those
and we'll move on to the office of
medicaid business and policy and as i
mentioned that's the big one that's
where most of the money is
in hhs so we'll start with the
uncompensated care fund
which is sometimes also known as dish
that's the federal term uh
disproportional share payments to
hospitals that serve a disproportionate
share of
uh indigent patients basically
these are payments to hospitals to make
up for
uncompensated care from two sources one
is individuals without
insurance coverage who haven't been able
to pay their bill
or whose insurance coverage didn't pay
the entire bill
and the other is the gap between what
medicaid pays for services and the
actual cost to providing those services
so combined those are the hospitals
uncompensated care and the state makes
an effort
along with the federal government to
reimburse them for that uncompensated
care
we fund that via a medicaid enhancement
tax on hospital
net patient service revenue now in the
past and i'm going
back in back into some of the history
here
the state collected met
matched it with federal funds and then
sent back to the hospitals immediately
that resulted in a federal audit
that resulted in the state paying back a
significant sum of money in
overpayments to hospitals and following
that audit
the state back in 2009 i think for the
first time
revised the the formula for dish
payments to hospitals
that revision followed by subsequent
revisions ended up in a slew of lawsuits
and the result is the agreement that we
have today that was put in place by 20
in 2018
and if we scroll down to the next page
here you can see the details of that
so the hospital pays back out to the
state rather pays back out to the
hospitals
an amount equal to 86 of that revenue in
the form of uncompensated care payments
an amount equal to five percent of that
revenue in the form of provider rate
increases
and up to 250 000 per year to each
deemed a disproportionate share
the difference between this and the
previous situation
is that hospitals don't necessarily get
back
exactly what they paid in some may get
more than they paid in and met revenue
some may get back less
but they're not uh they're not held
harmless as they were
2000s
so of that net revenue that the state
collects a portion is paid out to the
hospitals and uncompensated care as i
just mentioned
a portion is dedicated to the state's
medicaid managed care program
so that met that's put towards the
effectively reduces general funds spent
on medicaid because absent that met
revenue
the general fund would need to cover the
i have a costs here yes so
who who are the legislative subject
matter
experts in the history of the met
i i would imagine we may have people on
the committee division three committee
now
that were actually involved in
negotiating these details
was
i think probably neil and maybe mary
jane was involved
i i was i yes i was i was on the
the committee that we met throughout the
summer of i can't remember what summer
but
it seemed like a long a long summer and
i'd like to talk agreement you about
okay uh so moving on
to medicaid care management
this is the single biggest component of
the hhs budget
this is the traditional medicaid program
for individuals who are
eligible as a result of their financial
status and their
falling into one one eligible category
or another
you can see that in including the
children's health insurance program
which is budgeted separately but was
previously part of the medicaid
managed care program the current
operating budget appropriated 743
million dollars and 20
and 760 million dollars and 21 for
medicaid managed care
and the agency budget request including
additional prioritized needs
goes up to 813 million and 22 and 802
million in
23. this i believe is the only
program for which i've shown total funds
rather than specifically general funds
for the reason that i just mentioned
because the met revenue that goes
towards medicaid managed care
can be thought of as general funds
because it effectively reduces the
general funds needed
so moving down we have the granted
advantage health care program
this is the expanded medicaid program
that went into effect as a result of the
federal affordable care act
it's been restructured a couple times
over the years most recently
in 2018. currently
under federal law the federal share of
program costs is 90
and the state share program cost is 10
under current federal law that's how the
funding mix
will remain so per that 2018 bill that
restructured
the expanded medicaid program uh the
non-federal share of cost is to be
funded from three sources
insurance premium tax revenue
attributable to premiums written for
revenue transferred from the alcohol
abuse prevention and treatment fund
and revenue received from an assessment
on insurers
one thing that i will point out about
this is that this program is
off budget so you will not see the
expanded medicaid program in the budget
that ultimately comes out
it does have an accounting unit
associated with it of course and i can
show you that at any time but it's not
actually
a part of the operating budget
it's funded by a special non-budgeted
trust fund established in statute
total expenditures for the program have
been roughly 400 million per year and
that was true in fiscal 20 as well
with expenditures of 418.3 million
dollars
moving on to the bureau of elderly and
several years ago again in the in the
mid 2000s
there was an agreement struck between
counties and the state
in which the state picks up
the costs of services for youth
and counties pick up most of the cost
for long-term care services
so as you scroll through the budget and
you take a look at
nursing home services for example you'll
see that those are overwhelmingly
county funds matched with federal funds
relatively little overall so in the 2021
nursing nursing facility services cost
were appropriated for a total of 270
million per year
and the state commitment was about 14 to
16 million per year with the rest
split between counties and the federal
government
county payments though are capped in
state statute
and the amount of that cap changes with
each budget
so this is something that will be
included in
the trailer bill so in the previous
trailer bill for example the one
currently in effect
the county cap was established at 123.4
million in fiscal 20 and 126.9 million
in fiscal 21.
typically that amount does go up a bit
each year
counties also receive an aggregate
credit of 5 million dollars per year
which is intended to prevent them from
paying more than they would have paid
under the previous cost
there are a couple ways that the state
tries to leverage
federal funds to help out the nursing
facilities both private nursing
facilities and county run nursing
facilities
one of those is the mqip program the
medicaid quality incentive program
which is funded by an assessment
sometimes colloquially known as the bed
tax
on nursing facility bed days
those funds are matched with federal
dollars and paid back out to
all nursing homes both public and
and private the pro-share program on the
other hand is specific to county nursing
homes
and that is an attempt to match federal
dollars with
state dollars to compensate nursing
county nursing homes for the difference
between
what medicaid pays for their services
and what medicare would pay for the same
services
yes okay i'm looking at
mqip okay a little slow on the uptake
here
but it looks like there's a five perc
5.5
effectively a tax on the nursing
facilities
we collect it and we turn around and
give it back to them
yep so we must be taking it from
different people than we give it to
so who are who are the donors and who
are the recipients
um well that i don't know off the top of
my head i know we used to have
and i'm sure i can find a breakdown of
how enquip
is distributed between private nursing
homes in the aggregate and county
nursing homes in the aggregate
i'm not sure if we ever had a breakdown
by each specific
nursing home uh but i'll see if we i'll
see what we can find on that
it's that's not a huge priority i'm just
i just
when i just it just seems like we're
taking money and putting in one pocket
and paying it out in the next and i just
curious about that um to some extent we
are but again it's an effort to match
federal dollars because everything that
we bring in is matched with federal
money and then
distributed back out to the nursing
homes representative irf had his hand up
for a moment or did you did jenna take
it down
it was the only to point out to you that
the real thing that's going on there
is the matching funds so it's actually
generating more money it's not just
taking out one pocket putting the others
take it out of the pocket matching it
and then splitting it back up again
fit to the same pockets with more money
yes
the department's permitted under its uh
medicaid state plan to apply a budget
neutrality
factor to payments made to
nursing facilities and the reason for
this
is to ensure that payments don't exceed
available appropriations so if the state
appropriates say
a total of 270 million dollars in funds
per year for nursing services but the
actual cost of services is more than
that
the rates need to be reduced accordingly
so if they need to be
so if the budget is 20
more 20 less than the cost of services
the rates will be reduced
by twenty percent in order to bring them
in line with the budget
uh we'll move down to the division of
behavioral health
and the bureau of drug and alcohol
services
the bureau provides oversight of
regional public health networks
and contracts with a variety of
providers to provide
impaired driver rehabilitation service
programs among
many other programs it's also
responsible for oversight
of for-profit methadone clinics
and this i believe you had a question
about this earlier representative
edwards um
this is where this is where new futures
would come into the
picture some of the funding under this
division
scrolling down to the governor's
commission on alcohol and drug abuse
prevention
five percent of gross liquor profits are
collected and distributed
to the governor's commission which
regularly meets and votes on
and votes to approve contracts
that percentage was in statute for many
years
but as you can see from fiscal 2004
through fiscal 2015 the legislature
suspended it
every year over that entire period and
ultimately appropriated an amount that
was
smaller than the five percent
from 2016 through 2018 though the
formula was changed
from 1.7 to 3.4 percent it bounced
around a little bit
but the legislature made an effort to
give to the alcohol commission
the full amount of funding that was
allowed by statute
and finally in 2018 as part of
the extension of the expanded medicaid
program
the full five percent was reinstated and
the governor's commission now gets that
that that five percent has to be
transferred to the grand advantage
health care trust fund
to pay for the cost of the expanded
medicaid program with the department
essentially
backfilling that amount to fund the
governor's commission
as of now that backfill comes from
we'll move on to community mental health
services
the largest components of this i think
representative
erf has a question here when you use the
word donations there is that in quotes
um it's it is a voluntary donation
there's
there's an agreement with the state i
believe but it's a it's a voluntary
donation there's nothing in state
statute
that requires them to do it okay thank
you
so if we move on to community mental
health services uh one of the main
accounts in there
is the cmh program support account
and that funds uh 10 community mental
health centers throughout the state i
believe there are now 10
and that received a general fund
appropriation of 22 million in fiscal 20
and 25 million and 21.
you can see the agency budget request
moving on to new hampshire hospital and
glencliff home
for the elderly there was a lot of
activity surrounding new hampshire
hospital in the 20 20
21 budget uh specifically the trailer
bill appropriated five million dollars
for an inpatient psychiatric facility
for children
as well as 8.75 million for the
construction of a new
25 bed facility for adults on the new
i don't believe those projects have gone
forward
but the department again will be in a
better position to talk about those when
moving on to developmental services
this is a significant part of the
medicaid program and state statute
requires the department to budget the
full costs of services
for persons with developmental
disabilities and acquired brain disorder
brain disorders and also requires the
legislative
legislature to provide sufficient
funding for those services
the operating budget contained 173
million in fiscal 20 and 183 million in
fiscal 21
and you can see uh that the agency's
general fund request goes up a bit to
192 million and 22 and 212 million and
and i believe the intent of those
requests is to fully fund developmental
services for the
eligible populations and finally last
but not least moving on to the veterans
home which is not actually part of hhs
but it is part of division three's
purview uh the veterans homes
budget request is relatively flat
they're asking for a little bit more
they had 18 million and 18.4 million and
and they're requesting 18.3 and 19.1
million in the upcoming budget
so i have a question there and it's
actually a a request of the veterans
home when they come to present to us
okay um full full disclaimer
i'm eligible to be put away in this
veterans home someday
so
having said that i i would just be
curious
what uh given their average census
uh i would like to know how much they
spend
per patient say per year
whatever the denominator is per day per
year per month whatever
per patient per period compared to
say a typical county home in new
hampshire
okay i'd like to just understand
if um if we're if we're doing what we
should for veterans if we're gold
plating it relative to county care
i just i'd like to i just would like to
know relatively
how we're doing is that something they
typically provide anyways
that sort of comparison um not
necessarily
but i can let them know what you're
looking for and they should be able to
uh come in with that
i'll let them pick the benchmark they
can compare to
i just it should be a reasonable
benchmark is all i ask so that we can do
an apples to apples for close to it
okay okay do you have anything else to
to wrap up this is a great presentation
i notice your style's a little different
than mr kane's
i'm glad he was here for that you'll
enjoy that one
oh i think you're i think you're muted
representative
oh i i saw him on there i wouldn't have
said it otherwise
i was breathing off off camera i'm
breathing
okay good
oh you're muted again let's see
i'm trying to mute in case the dogs go
nuts
so unless you have any uh summary wrap
up on that i think that was great do you
want to take questions does anyone have
any
questions given that we just went
i'm not seeing any okay we can come back
if there are some
so the next topic is discussion on
process committee deadline
zoom meeting best practices um
i uh i threw some bullets in here
that i wanted to make sure we talked
about
and that is that uh for as far as the
eye can see
we're going to have either uh well from
here on it's going to be hybrid
i believe that there's been a commitment
from the lba
to have us set up in the committee room
for
uh one week from today uh but there is
absolutely
no pressure for me to for anybody
to show up in person i i want to be
there in person
but there's no pressure from me on
anyone i
i'd kind of like to know in advance
where you think you're going to be just
in case i want to chat with you i'd like
to know how to do that
um is there any any uh commentary on on
hybrid meetings
i got a i got a note from uh somebody in
uh
leadership that they think that we could
use the house chamber for a
finance committee meeting briefing and
the
plan might be for us to do that in the
february
presentation so we can get a whole
committee in there that's where they put
24 senators
and we could be in as they have little a
desk and a little microphone at each of
the places that are set up in the
house chamber and so we could we could
meet there with separation and so on
and each be able to be on a mic when we
had a question
and that might be what we do for the
governor's budget presentation because
they supposedly changed the whole
hvac system in the
in the house chamber so that the proper
ventilation and
i guess um ultraviolet lights have been
installed in the
events and so on so they think it's it's
just about ready so
well that's good to hear i think they
put a lot of detail in the house
calendar
that i didn't intend to repeat for
everyone but
i i do think a lot of effort is going on
to
um to respect cdc recommendations on the
precautions and to
all right um representative walter do
you you have anything you want to add
on the discussion of hybrid you got your
are you talking uh i do have my uh my
hand up
yes ma'am representative weiler do you
know are we for sure
going to have the briefing from the
governor on his budget on
we had an earlier discussion and nobody
knows for sure
whether we'll have it on the 11th or the
16th the 15th
possibly being a holiday so you know one
would hope we would get it before the
holiday rather than after
but those for sure yet
unfortunately okay could i have a
follow-up to that
i also um will we also be seeing
um house bill 2 at the same time
i think we put that in law last time
that it had to be we did
i think you did in the last budget so
yeah i did
traditionally we did we did yeah
and so okay and hopefully it's delivered
at the same point because that's what i
remember we put in law
okay great thank you unreasonable to
wait and
see it much later representative norgren
i saw your hand go up but i'm gonna
allow mr cain to speak first in case he
answers your question
sure i i just wanted to add um that
the governor may present his
typically what happens if the governor
presents the full house or does the
state of the state on his budget
we've heard it could be the 11th
although that is in about two weeks so
it's it's pretty quick um i think
f how he does that is probably something
that the governor's office is discussing
with leadership right now whether it be
similar to his
um state of the union address or his
inauguration
where it is remote but what
representative weiler was mentioning
is that he usually the governor usually
does he or she comes into the house
finance committee
to present their budget kind of a kick
off to the
budget process and we'll come in with
the budget director so his new budget
director
matt mayo is his name and i think on the
16th
and i think again leadership
representative wyler janet will work
with the governor to see if he's
available
hopefully on the 16th would come and
present
uh either virtually or um or in person
probably virtually to the full finance
committee
and that would be in a hybrid capacity
as representative weiler had stated
the house chamber actually when they did
upgrade the air conditioning they
did a full upgrade of the entire
ventilation system so that is
in the whole complex that's one room
that is actually a safe room and that's
why
the senate's able to meet there the
again smaller group the only 24 of them
but it does have the proper air exchange
has been set up
uh with hybrid capabilities so that
members who do not attend are still able
to participate
um as well as the agencies if they're
presenting
um are able and so i think that's the um
that's the game plan i think there's
still obviously
it's a couple weeks anything can happen
between now and then but i know that
uh leadership's working to um
come up with the plan for that okay
so um i don't know if it was technology
or representative nordgren
did you did you get your question
answered do you still have something
no i think i think probably we'll know
more or later i'm just
obviously concerned about showing up and
the mask rule and what that whole
uh in that room what will be the
situation with mass
and keeping people safe so i assume
there'll be more information coming
i would assume that too and i just would
want to reiterate that
uh if you're not comfortable coming in
please don't
and we'll try to figure out how to
accommodate you so that you feel like
you're a full participant
thank you so uh
the next step uh public access before
during and after so
uh i just want to remind you that once
you get on zoom
uh you might uh already be
accessible to the public view and
so i i just would caution you to make
sure that
your setting and your dress code and
everything
uh what you're saying to your your
spouse all of that stuff
you know that may be live in public uh
as soon as you turn on zoom so that's
that's just a caution i i've asked
um i've asked uh mr ripple to let me
know
um if they if they go live
um but i i i correct me if i'm wrong did
i say
um let me tell you that we can go live
like five minutes before
or what did i say recording i forget
what i said
uh you talked to me i think briefly
representative edwards about
um like five we'll wait for you to give
the okay
before the video's turned on because if
it is if it is
a case where members are getting ready
getting settled there's no need to have
that video on
um but we'll wait for you if for some
reason you forget to notify us we'll
definitely start it by the time uh once
you open the meeting so we'll make sure
there's no excess
video i just don't want anybody
accidentally embarrassing themselves
with us being public when we shouldn't
have to be
so um also
dress codes and non-partisan backdrops i
i would hope that we all think of our
virtual environment
as an extension of
the decorum of the house meaning that
we don't while we don't have a dress
code i think each individual
attempts to address professionally when
they when they go to
committee and so because this is subject
to
public uh viewing i i would hope that
you would use that same dress code
and then we're not supposed to have any
partisan backdrops
so so if you have any flags
hanging in the back uh please don't show
it that's i think the virtual background
helps
protect against that sort of thing
and an extension of that is i
i would like you all to be comfortable
leaving your cameras
active during the meeting and
we can talk about that but i i think as
i read article 38 of the new hampshire
constitution last 10 to 15 words
of it really to me say that we are meant
to conduct our legislative business
um in public view with full transparency
so so to me that means we should have
our cameras on
um and be live now so
so representative bean i don't want to
put you on the spot is do you have a
technology issue there
um
i don't know much about this tablet it's
it's relatively new
i'll have to uh talk to somebody
that's more technological than i am
and see if i can get this squared away
between now and then
okay i would not ask you to spend
additional money
on technology i'd i'd just say if you
have the capability it'd be great if you
would leverage it for um being
in viewing and then uh representative
nordgren uh i'd i'd
love to hear what you have to say go
ahead um
for full disclosure i'm actually in
dartmouth-hitchcock
uh dealing with heart issues so i could
turn it on and you could see my room
but um hopefully i'll be back in
operation next week
well i i hope i hope you have a great
visit and you
have a full and speedy recovery i would
not
ask anyone to have their privacy
violated in any way
i'm just saying you know as a general
rule
i i think we should be transparent
that's a that's a an aspirational goal
but you should definitely do it in a way
in which
and i it's a beautiful room by the way
and it looks like they ran your iv very
well so
right and i'm watching the construction
site i'm supervising
uh are there any other comments like i
don't want anyone to feel
abused and have their privacy taken from
them but
uh is are there any comments about this
representative weiler
you're the chair is this consistent with
the guidance you're given other
divisions
so if if you ever have an issue with
that just reach out and and talk to me
i'm i'm i'm open
um so as i understand
the feedback i'm getting from other
people who've run zoom meetings is that
when people
get on zoom they're they're kind of
isolated in their own
room and they don't have the same
benefit
of watching people's body languages and
so they tend to run on a lot longer
so so if we are in a hybrid situation
and you're
speaking remotely i would just ask you
to be
keep it succinct you know just just keep
in mind
that there is this behavioral issue
where people
speaking to zoom kind of like i'm doing
now just run on and on and on and on and
and we just need to keep it sync hit it
and get it
um and uh in line with that
i would say um in the previous
committees i've been on
the chair was in each committee was very
rigid
or maybe the words discipline very
disciplined
on allowing one question at a time from
a representative
and after the question the
representative would go back to the
chairman to say
i'd like a follow-up okay because
because
we're already handicapped i think by the
technology
what i what i think i'd like to do is
once you start
asking questions to kind of just give me
an idea how many questions you've got
and just keep rolling i don't i
i don't think it's good given the
limitations of the virtual environment
to have to keep going back and forth
playing ping pong
with each question so so representative
wallner you have your hand up
do you want to thank you i think you
just covered it actually
um since the finance committee is a
little different because
a lot of the questioning that we have is
of department heads or
agency people to um answer our financial
the questions about finances
often you'll ask a question and often it
brings you to another question because
you need to
sort of go down that track
um and if you have to wait then to ask
to ask the follow-up question after
everybody else has
done it it it breaks the chain of
thought really so
i think if we can have follow-up
questions and try to keep them
okay good so so you're not you're not
disagreeing we're all aligned there
no no i think it goes without saying
that i reserve the right to
cut off questioning at some point but i
just would like to know
i would just like to have some idea how
you know how long it needs to run
for you to be comfortable we're making
big decisions and i don't want anyone to
feel like they
they don't have the information they
need to make their own
um anything else on the on on those two
topics because
um i my next step would be laptops and
fluids
so my thought on this is certainly if
you're in a virtual environment
you can have um your
a beverage with you uh
i'm i and i would even say if we're
meeting with the department
uh i view those as probably more like
working sessions than public hearings
i i would tend to say if you want to
have a cup of coffee with you
while we're here in department briefs
that that's okay
would you would you agree or disagree mr
chairman
representative weiler i i don't want to
if you're in your own home
and i've seen it on most of the zone
calls people taking a sip of something
uh you're in your own home you're fairly
comfortable so i don't think anybody can
object to that but
when we're in we're in the committee
room it's
because the cleaning staff doesn't want
to clean up crumbs and
right coffee stains okay so and then
we had a pretty hard no laptop rule
uh in the previous committees but the
world has changed
and now i can see us needing a laptop so
that we know what's going on with the
virtual
team members so so i would ask
that you you don't play games or goof
around on your
laptop but if you need it up so that you
can participate
you know more fully in the meeting i i
i'm i'm pro-laptop in committee hearings
is there is there any just disagreement
okay um now hearing none
uh that sort of wraps up the discussion
oh i didn't see it thank you thank you
so much because if i couldn't have my um
as everybody on the committee that's
been there knows i live on the laptop
and um and take lots of notes so um
if i can't have my mini i would probably
have a nervous breakdown or somehow
um don't know what i'd do during the
session but um i don't play games and i
don't do whatever but
it's invaluable to me to be able to go
back and check
notes of what um happened and so forth
so i really appreciate
that you would let me continue that
practice
of having my laptop to take notes with
thank you i am fine with that and as
long as we're not
violating the finance chairs guidelines
i'm okay with it i would just ask you to
for one boundary condition uh a reason
not to have laptops is because if you
have the public there
the public wants to be able to you know
see you
and interact with you and not think that
you're you know messing around so
so as you're using your laptop if you
could just
push position it in a place where you
still have
visualization of the public that would
be great my mini is about
an inch bigger than your your cell phone
so oh
okay well that's not a problem um
all right so i had sent
out a template on some things that i
would
like um to have the the departments come
in
ready to ask uh i should try that
you know as long as we're doing this i
should try to do a share
do you want to tell me how to share
go to your share screen at the bottom of
the um
thing and hit that there should be a
um right underneath the pictures if
you're looking at gallery view kind of
in the middle of the screen
yep so are you seeing something called
division three chairman's template or
are you seeing much there it is
yes yes oh wow god this is so great
okay so um i don't know if you've had a
chance to look at it i
i did float it by representative walner
and irf
um and mr ripple before and maybe
uh maybe some others so so so these are
the kinds of things that i think i would
like to know routinely
when they're relevant to a particular
department and representative wallner
asked me a good question
kind of the goldilocks question of of
which departments are too big to be
answering these kinds of questions and
which of them are too small and i don't
really have
a a good guideline on that
unless mr ripple or mr kane you've come
up with one
i i would tend to just send it to the
departments and say
answer to these to the question that you
perceive them
to be relevant to the committee's
decision making
and and don't go reinvent the wheel
or try too hard to come up with answers
right
i would i'd leave it to common sense
unless you've got
a protocol you'd like to recommend
i think that makes sense i i was unable
to come up with a hard and fast rule i i
think i mentioned when we talked about
this that
the department puts out a briefing book
with all accounting units
greater than a million dollars now that
would be
much too low that would be much too low
a level i think to provide all of this
information but they do provide some of
it in there so
some of that information is already
available and perhaps they could fill in
so so i don't know how many of you i
don't want to go line by line on this
but i do want to make sure that if you
think there's a question on here that
doesn't make sense to you that i uh i
edit it before we send it to the
department
or if i'm missing something that you you
would like to normally know
we can add that and and i'd like to give
this to
release this to mr ripple tomorrow so
that the departments have a heads up
that we're asking this and
i think i saw representative rogers hand
go up and then representative nordgren
what do you have representative rogers
yeah my my only
request would be that we understand that
not every and not every question on this
i think can be answered by the
department in that this is as much more
of a business model
and when we're dealing with um health
and human service agencies
there's not always a business answer in
that
um while i know that the
people would like to say that they're
customers and that they
they have a black and white answer
there's a lot more gray areas that we
deal with here
than in then and quite often than other
parts of state government when we for
instance deal with the
disability community there's an awful
lot of gray area
the way the pandemic for instance has
affected them
um with a lot of them lost their
caregivers because of the pandemic
because of
the way that it affected them it's very
hard for agencies to then come back
and predict how this is going to affect
in the future
two years if it changes we don't know
when it changes or if
it however um i think there's a lot more
gray area than can be specifically
answered here so i guess i would ask
that
um we not be kind of
um a hundred percent say you have to
answer this
specifically because i think that
there's just
too much that they specifically can't be
answered
i think they can attempt to but i just
look at all the different areas and
my experience and i know that sharon and
mary jane have even more
but when you deal with child care the
disability community
the elderly community that just the way
the pandemic has affected them over the
last year
and the way it will continue to and how
they project out and how they even look
at
what's happened it's going to be very
difficult to
answer some of these with black and
white answers black and white
is just impossible i think i can
appreciate that
i i i think if uh well one
i i don't want them to over engineer the
effort to answer the questions
i i this is the kind of things that i
tend to think about
and i think if they come across a
question that this just doesn't fit
if they were to say that and say why it
doesn't fit i think
that would facilitate learning on my
part if not others
so i think maybe if we can just put a
kind of provision at the beginning of it
that we do understand
that that's a possibility yes ma'am i
will
uh work to um make this purpose
statement a little bit
uh responsive to what you just said
thank you you bet so so
in order i i think i had representative
nordgren up next and then representative
uh weiler and walner in that order
yeah i i think i was just gonna make a
nuts and boat comment
so whenever the governor presents the
budget
particularly to the house and senate
then immediately we get this giant book
that's about six inches tall
and uh those of us who've been around
around a long time
we take out uh section
five of that huge book and we put it in
its own little binder
so i guess the question will be that um
mr ripple and mr kane can put on their
list
of those people who then are going to do
virtual
we will need to have that section of the
budget
i'll let mr ripple answer that since
um and i can answer it just so you put
kevin on the
spot yeah well um so that's what we're
dealing with right now is
um the logistics of
making sure that members who are in
person as well as members who are remote
uh have the same materials and so we
will do that represent our
our plan and we we were talking about
this last couple days
within the office our plan is to make
sure that everyone gets a hard copy
of the governor's budget if you want us
to separate that out
we can do that and separate just um
category five for the division members
um maybe we will talk about that because
maybe we can break it down into the
three divisions
um like three sections so instead of
getting one big
uh governor's budget you would get three
each division you'd you'd get the whole
thing everyone would get the whole thing
but you'd have them broken down so you
could always grab your section only as
you're writing notes and going through
that and so
yeah yeah we'll talk we'll talk uh with
the staff in the best way how to do that
just to make sure you each get
everything and your own
okay okay i'm sure you're on the case i
just wanted to bring it up to the new
members
well thank you and if and if you can uh
basically hardwire it
so that we get it the way you think it
should be that would be really kind of
nice i think
yep so so representative weiler i
believe you were next sir
thank you mr chairman uh one of the
things that is our
duty in going over the budget year by
year is to
look at areas of efficiency and every
once in a while we're in it
in a situation where we have to make
some pretty drastic changes
so one of the things i would add in
in writing to these different groups
that come into us would be
what you consider the most vital part of
your agency
and what which part is the least
vital and you probably get
90 of them 80 will say oh it's all
vital but every once in a while you will
get a disclosure where somebody says
well
this such and such part was imposed on
me i'm not comfortable with it blah blah
blah
or it's not as important as it was when
i first took
over but it's becoming less important it
kind of gives us a clue
as to where we might be making the most
changes to save the most money
there might be some part of it that has
almost become you know
no longer relevant but they just keep
people there because they don't want to
lay anybody off
i mean that's that's kind of extreme but
there are there are instances where
we've seen things like that that
or maybe that division should be
somewhere else or that
piece of that the operation should be
somewhere else but
we're going to get some serious
questions now about sununu youth center
and if we did make further reductions
what would we do with this expensive uh
building that was not put up that long
ago
to fully utilize it those are the things
that we've got to look at and there's a
big piece of property there that
i'm sure developers and the city of
manchester would like to
get their hands on so those are things
we've got to be thinking of when we go
through all this
and uh you know that we'd be the ones
that would have to make those changes
because quite often they have to be made
in law
so those are just things that you might
get some
if you asked the agencies what's your
most vital
function and what's your least so i'm
hoping we get some
honest answers that might give us a hint
thank you
so as i was thinking about that i
i could just imagine from my days being
a government employee
uh how you would not want to put in
writing
the least vital part of your department
because you would know that
it's going to get stomped on and get
your
chain of command upset at you at the
same time so
so i wonder i wonder if if there's um if
we we should talk about that some more
if you don't mind sir okay
[Laughter]
oh thank you i'm i'm sort of going back
to the template
but i did i want to just mention again
and i think
it's already been mentioned that one of
the most useful documents we're going to
have
is the briefing book from health and
human services
i don't know if all the new members have
actually had a look at
previous briefing books but it's very
very complete
i would say most of the questions that
are on this template
are answered that you do have some that
were
would might not have been on it but i
think you'll find it to be
probably one of the best documents we
have as we go through the budget
it really lays out um the case for
what the department's doing and all the
financial
information um it's it's quite a good
document
okay well i'll i'll take a look at that
i have not seen one i've not looked at
one yet
but thank you for the advice
and i don't want i don't want redundancy
i'm going to ask him to do something
twice i just
want to make sure that this is within
um representative erf
this is a question or a comment back for
lba again regarding documents
if when you do the splitting up of the
physical document the budget you'd also
do it
electronically and posting those as well
same thing with the brief ebook and also
the same thing with any documents that
or presentations that the department is
going to bring forward if they could
have those posted
or available the day before so we could
download them and have them ready to go
while they're going through them
that's our plan going forward we'd love
for all the agencies to provide any
documents ahead of time instead of the
day of
uh kevin had briefly mentioned it this
year we're going to have division
specific
sites on our website so that every
document you have
will be presented and what we can do is
yes as you said we could have category 5
for instance specifically a link to that
on the websites too but i'll work with
kevin i'll work on breaking that pdf
down when we do receive it from the
governor
um in a division friendly manner and
then we'll make sure that we
post everything and hopefully keep being
searchable
yes and keep it searchable that's the
key and i have talked to uh
on the fiscal uh this past time was not
searchable but we'll make sure that all
the documents are searchable
okay thank you so
um our next meeting uh is scheduled for
one week from today at 1 pm
um we've we've had new futures in
waypoint
ask us if they could come in and talk to
us
and i the guidelines i gave them was
no more than 10 minutes i gave them some
guidelines on
the kinds of things that they should put
in their document
i ask them to send the documents on a
read ahead basis so we can distribute it
you can look at it
i i thought it would be okay to schedule
this because we still have
a little uh dead time between now and
when we really get to work on the
governor's budget
and this might be a way to learn
more about the department um if you
don't think this
adds value to you as a committee member
it's okay for you to not come but we'll
do a public meeting
and it'll be open to the public um i i
don't really like to talk to lobbyists
uh one-on-one just as a general rule i
i'd like those conversations to be as
public and transparent as possible
and so this is a way to do it the the
the other thing
uh that that representative weiler and i
have talked about
is to have um the ag's office the doj
come over and talk to us about
lawsuits my original idea was i
wanted to kind of know about pending
lawsuits so we could have some idea of
what kind of contingency risk reserves
we might need to be thinking about but
but uh but i've been convinced that
that's probably not going to
be available to us because of uh the
need for confidentiality and not
uh sharing information uh that shouldn't
be in the public domain so
so representative weiler has suggested
instead that we kind of take a
historical
view of the kind of lawsuits that are
hitting dhhs
and um you know you know representative
weiler do you
do you want to talk a little bit about
uh your idea on this i think
i think mr ripple's been in contact with
the doj but
everyone should kind of hear what you're
thinking
well as as you and i discussed um
and then the accountability for hhs
isn't very high uh you could have the
same person
getting in trouble all the time and
being sued a lot of the time but once
once the lawsuit is filed it goes over
the attorney general
and if there's a settlement the attorney
general comes to fiscal and says i need
some money
and we put a certain amount of money in
their budget anyway for
settlements but we never put in as much
as we think we'll need
because it becomes a target for lawyers
so
what we do is we put in an amount they
come back to fiscal but
the hhs gets to wash their hands
of what could be a problem and it could
be a certain person that's a problem and
so the accountability leaves the agency
it goes over the ag
and you know i i'm not comfortable with
the ag not even
involving us i mean i've i've done
things in the budget there was a lawsuit
that
that occurred and i waited for the ag to
interview me
to know how best to reply never got an
interview i called them up and said
what statement do you want from me oh
we're okay
so you know it seems to me we're not
being properly represented
by the by the department of justice
if we're being sued over our actions we
should be involved
and they're just totally ignoring us
and i i don't find that very good
practice of law
so that's a point i'm gonna make with
them and if if we had
some accountability within hhs so that
if they had the same person getting sued
multiple times for the same sort of
behavior what are they doing about it
you know they're just ignoring it and
brushing it off to the ag so
i think that's a conversation we have to
have thank you
thank you sir um are any comments
on on that i mean not very loud jess
uh are there any comments on that i i
think from the
uh the folks that have been experienced
in this field for quite a while
all right i'm not seeing any hands up no
pressure
so um all right so at this point
it's uh uh i just want to reiterate that
next meeting
is an invitation only meeting for the
division
three i if you if you want to dial in a
little late because you don't need to
hear
uh uh what what uh new features or
waypoint may say to us
but you are interested in the doj then
then dial in a little bit late that's
all fine with me
um and then we'll just we'll just if if
if we're going to take attendance we'll
take attendance
uh more we'll make sure the attendance
is correct at the end of the meeting
all right last call for comments
anything for the good of com
the committee uh normally if we were in
person i would go around the table and
just
you know have you say yes or no but but
in this format i'll
if you if you have a last comment or
something for the good of the commit
committee just raise your hand and i'll
all right not seeing any uh i
do we need motions to adjourn or or do i
just say hey
i think we're done that's a good
question representative i did reach out
to jim ciancio who's the house legal
counsel to verify that and it's okay for
the chair
um to adjourn the meeting without having
a roll call
all right well then um
not seeing any hands and knowing that
everyone's been invited to say something
before we close i think we're done
so so this was um
almost two hours it was a little long uh
the next meeting i i think is going to
be well under
90 minutes um and so i do appreciate
your participation and reach out to me
if you
have comments that you you want to talk
about offline